hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zum schlechtesten
video aller zeiten von mir hier auf
meinem kanal jedes video man da jedes
bei der videos ist extrem schlecht
allerdings erreicht das heutige video
neue galaxien von daher darf ich euch
ganz herzlich hierzu heute begrüßen
denen kriege ich nicht weil er sich
zusammenzieht herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen episode addario habe ich
schon länger nicht gespielt habe ich ja
damals im rahmen von mobile band ist mit
luca mal wieder gespielt und habe mega
gut bei euch an deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich bringe jetzt mal auch eine
neue episode auf dem pc aus ihr seht
recht ich bin gerade platz 59 aber
erstmal noch mal auf den titel
einzugehen und allgemein auf die ganze
situation warum ich jetzt noch nicht
fett geschnittene habe da seid ihr
eigentlich von mir gehört dass es jetzt
schlag auf schlag schnitt et cetera pp
schnitzt wahrscheinlich ist die mehrzahl
von schnitt luca ich wie ihr
wahrscheinlich unschwer erkennen oder
erhören könnten krank das wie der typ
hier unten heißt den ich gerade ja ich
bin tot
das würde ich gern begeben denn mir geht
es richtig beschissen also mir gehts
echt mir ging es noch nie so scheiße ihr
werdet ihr den kompletten video hier
keinen einzigen schnitt von mir sehen
ihr werdet die ganze zeit hintergrund
musik hören die pausieren oft wenn ich
irgendwie bald themen rede oder gerade
mal lacher oder keine ahnung was
allerdings wird hat heute nicht der fall
sein weil ich habe 38,64 kann ich euch
auch gerne beweisen falls ja sagt und
was die sache schlimmer als es ist saudi
arabien krieg wie nicht hier
ich hoffe man kennt das ich glaube man
erkennt es überhaupt nicht 8m ist jetzt
gerade neu robert kann ich dass ich wie
zeigen offenbar dass auch scheißegal
guck mal der instagram story da seht ihr
mein komplettes leiden ich habe leidlich
liegt seit sechs tagen also seit montag
liege ich nur im bett aufs sofa ich bin
zwischendurch mal aufgestanden für zwei
stunden videos gemacht aber auch nur
videos an denen ich jetzt nicht so lange
gesessen habe sage ich mal also die
google bewertungen das ging relativ
schnell und die anderen sachen die ich
hoch geladen da habe auch allerdings da
habe ich mir einfach gedacht kommen
bevor jetzt wieder kein video kommt über
karneval kam ja schon nicht so viele
videos weil halt karneval war in köln
das ist ja somit das größte fest dass es
hier gibt im kreis und ja da habe ich
mir gedacht kommen jetzt karneval vorbei
ist ab dienstag sich wieder richtig
durch mache mir mega gedanken für videos
macht kommen ja das ist so richtig kette
wie wir uns gerade jahren nee ich hab
mir auf jeden fall gedacht kommen ich
hatte nein
und verdammte scheiße jetzt mich
verkackt glaube ich das war jetzt nicht
so gut ich hab noch keinen anderen
spieler gefressen und jetzt nicht wieder
tot
naja gut ja ich habe mir gesagt nach
karneval kommen lukrativste durch mit
videos blabla
ich meine ich wusste dass ich nach
karneval eventuell klar man hat auch den
ein oder anderen ein oder andere kölsch
getrunken der ein oder anderen bar und
eventuell was auch am regnet und man war
leicht bekleidet unterwegs so dass man
selbst schuld wenn man leicht erkältet
ist allerdings ist es bei mir halt immer
so als hätte mich kriegs mit einer
kleinen split decision da guck mal hier
erwarte ich fresse zu müssen was da wird
das wird jetzt ein neues ziel hier seien
viel zu fressen
das hast du davon kam
so kann ich da oben auch noch wohl nicht
auf dich war und jetzt david o mein gott
sie jedoch rein du bist doch größer luca
es kann doch nicht sein ich bin doch
safe größer er ist einfach richtig aber
gerade auf okay okay war
ich kann gerade das war auch grad kaya
was sollte ich sagen ich wollte ein
gericht ich durch die nach karneval und
ich dachte halt schon ja ich werde ein
bisschen erkältet ich werd krank
allerdings ist es bei mir sonst war so
dass ich dann krank bin was ich jetzt so
viel das bitte ich mich mal sehr gute
idee luca direkt bitten wenn da ein
anderer spieler ist er ich lebe ja echt
am limit gerade ich weiß noch was gab
videos von mira dario platz 1 oder
irgendwie so hat millionen aufrufe von
mir wollte ich gar nicht aufnehmen
damals und dann habe ich einfach so ein
bisschen gezockt beim lernen und
plötzlich danke oder der lieb ich ein
bisschen gezockt beim lernen plötzlich
platz eins ich weiß nicht wie ich das
geschafft habe ich bin grad platz 41 und
es fühlt sich anders als nähe ich dachte
auf jeden fall notwendig aufs thema
zurückzukommen ich dachte auf jeden fall
ich krieg das easy hin ich besiegte
erkältung in 14 tagen und dann wird das
schon
stattdessen ja ich war dienstag mittwoch
donnerstag freitag und jetzt ist samstag
und ich wollte heute eigentlich habe ich
meinem vater geschenkt schön ja im
stadion in köln gegen schalke spielt
gerade wenn ich das video aufnehmen aber
habe ich jetzt auch abgesagt weil ich
will jetzt auch nicht noch mal der
eltern dann irgendwie doof anstecken
geschweige denn stadion wenn es hier vor
paar tagen noch anschneiden waren köln
das wir hätten ein immunsystem nicht so
toll gefunden und ich habe jetzt aber
trotzdem gedacht ich neben video für
euch auf heute morgen bin ich ganz
ehrlich ging es mir doch deutlich besser
als jetzt gerade aber das ist ja immer
so dass man zum abend hin noch ein
bisschen schwächer wird weil man über
den tag über den tag über dann halt auf
beiden war und so weiter und so fort
aber deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
kommen bevor ich mich jetzt hier hin
hocke und ich mal ihr seht es wenn ihr
in die augen schaut
ich bin nicht high oder auf drogen oder
sonst irgendwas ich bin einfach komplett
krank und deswegen habe ich mir das
gedacht ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwas
ok warte ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwie
groß der reaction aufnehmen wo ich mich
rod lache weil das kann nicht einfach
gerade dich viele leute haben ja also
ich habe euch auf instagram gefragt was
hochladen soll viele leute haben mir
geschrieben
block hoch wo ich mir einfach denke ich
liege nur bett so was sollte da sehen
ich gucke den ganzen tag in die
bundesliga und irgendwelche videos und
mehr passiert nicht immer bleibe also
ich weiß wie das der fed blocken soll
auf jeden fall habe ich dann gedacht
warum lebst du dich mal endlich wieder
ein uncut video hoch ich habe so was
schon mal gemacht vor bord zwei jahre
oder so das video heißt einfach dieses
videos uncut glaube ich da habe ich
trotzdem bisschen geschnitten so
zwischendurch die musik malaysia gemacht
ausgebaut ausgestellt zwischendurch dann
mal mein gott was macht der denn das
habe ich mir gezeigt wie man das machen
kann
dabei kann leertaste drücken da kann
also teile da rein schießt aber wirklich
billig abgeben von meiner warte hier
ich habe dabei ist da noch zumindest
irgendwie die musik ein bisschen
verändert wobei gott ist allerdings groß
aber jetzt gerade ich kann gar nichts
ist es tut so weh bei ganzer schädel ich
einfach auf den screen und mein kopf
explodiert ich weiß die kommentare
werden jetzt selbstverständlich voll
sein und da bin ich auch extrem dankbar
dafür und weiß einfach was ich habe und
was ich würde ja tolle community einfach
habe viele werden schon mir schreiben
das haben wir auch viele auf meine
instagram frage geantwortet was sich
hochladen soll halo karat gar nichts
hoch du bist krank heilerde ich kuriere
ich aus das macht am meisten sind
allerdings dachte ich wir herkommen
bevor ich jetzt irgendwie weiß ich nicht
wird der arzt eine viertelstunde
telefonieren ist es mehr oder weniger
genau das gleiche wenn ich hier mit euch
einfach ein bisschen aber durch einfach
sagen was gerade los ist
hallo liebe auf instagram folgen wissen
glaube ich dass ich jeden tag beim rewe
bin und mir einfach nur neue zitronen
kaufe hier in köln ist doch nicht so
dass leute haben es da käufe tätigen
viele machen ja wegen dem corona virus
verfallen jetzt total in panik und
kaufen alles alles leer im supermarkt
und kaufen sich da ja alles mögliche an
nudel und reis und alles was irgendwie
auch bei gott das könnte gerade gutes
manöver hier werden gibt mir denn ich
war ich bin krank den dorf soll das denn
man kommt noch eine runde
ich bin kein roboter habe so gut erkannt
das werde ich nie verstehen diese
komische dieses komische system das
steht einfach ich bin kein roboter muss
anklicken oder sagte er ja okay du bist
kein roboter so ein roboter das bestimmt
nicht gekonnt einfach draufklicken höre
gar keine sind ich könnte mir aber die
kommentare schreiben
die das hinkriegen aber woraus thema
zurückzukommen
das habe ich nicht mehr vergessen das
ist sicher schon wieder alle haben das
ist mir viel zu anstrengend hier gerade
alles ja viele decken sich gerade ein
mit irgendwelchen hamsterkäufen
spaghetti und nudeln spaghetti und
bügeln ist ja gut verkaufen einfach
komplett nudeln konserven und busen und
alles mögliche
bei uns im rewe hier ist das noch nicht
so der fall also hier kriegt sie noch
alles das einzige was gestern
ausverkauft war war kölsch also bier ich
weiß ja auf die kölner die hamsterkäufe
nicht so richtig verstehen aber ich
bitte mich mal da bitte ich jetzt ein
bisschen schneller die ganze scheiße
anwenden kann
die golf du wolltest schon immer zu mir
es ist nicht mehr egal wo die ja da habe
ich dich sehr gut lecker ja ich weiß
jetzt die kölner dass ich so richtig
verstehen aber hier in meinem revier war
nur kölsch ausverkauft weil ich sehr
stark
ich selbst habe ich jetzt nicht
eingedeckt werden welchen hamsterkäufe
ich finde immer noch sehr übertrieben
klar der korona virus also ich hab auch
viele nachrichten bekommen
es soll dazu ein update video hochladen
blabla habe ich bin immer noch der
gleichen meinung und klar ist es
mittlerweile so dass die
lega will endlich da wo mein gott ich
glaube der links okay okay das wird
jetzt grade spannend das wird jetzt
gerade sehr spannend aber ich habe mich
gut retten können das ding ist natürlich
klar die sterberate hat sich ein
bisschen nach oben entwickelt natürlich
la bruder du bist genau gleich groß doch
keinen sinn
aber wenn ich jetzt müssen wir fressen
kann ich dich vielleicht das doch nicht
fair hat der hilft ihm die ganze zeit
das doch nicht verkommen wir spielen
auch eine runde das immer so man sagt
dann so nee kommt noch eine letzte runde
die sie bei fifa also wenn der eine
verliert also kaum noch ein spiel
gewinnt der andere dann so erhalten
entscheidungsspiel immer so wer sich
verliert die ganze zeit den faden jack
oder einige leute mal einige leute mein
lokal hat auch mal ein update video dazu
hoch brauche ich nicht es ist für mich
immer noch genau das gleiche ins krass
wie leute in panik verfallen natürlich
ist er auch mein gott cage ich bin schon
wieder tot kam eine runde geht noch ich
bin immer noch der meinung dass die
leute das ziemlich krass übertreiben und
das sagt auch jeder von der bundes
gesundheitsbehörde und von der whu und
von den biologen dass die dass die
ansteckungsgefahr oder die die ich weiß
nicht genau wie das in der fachbegriff
dafür ist aber es ist aber noch gering
bis mäßig und klar natürlich wird es
sicher es wird das jetzt hoch gehen weil
die inkubationszeit einfach 2 wochen
beträgt und man kann dafür schön erstmal
und man kann davon ausgehen dass
natürlich jetzt gerade an karneval hier
in köln das fand ich auch bemerkenswert
dass das überhaupt stattgefunden hatte
hätte ich auch schon gedacht dass das
halt nicht stattfinden wird
weil halt in china und alle möglichen
messen werden abgesagt zum beispiel
jetzt in nürnberg irgendwie sollte
möbelmesse wurde abgesagt dagegen 1000
leute hin
karneval sind millionen menschen
unterwegs in köln und auch jetzt gerade
köln spiel gegen schalke standen des
ausverkaufs 50.000 leute hier in nrw wo
ist die meisten corona infizierten oder
verdachtsfälle in deutschland gibt
lassen wir einfach alles weiter
stattfinden natürlich da du kannst keine
vernünftige du kannst kein vernünftiges
wäre das hier rechts das muss doch
selbst erste platz sein oder hat er ja
okay dass der erste
diese erkrankung wie groß der ist im
gegenwärtigen keiner vorbei ich helfe
dem letzten bisschen watte bitteschön
vielleicht ein bisschen zurück rudi
etwas geholfen mir auch ein bisschen wie
lieb danke auch mein gott oh mein gott
wird man okay ich bin dann mal weg
ja ich habe gerade meine mutter schreibt
wir sind auch ein bisschen krank dass du
mir halt einfach leid für leute die ja
jetzt nicht komplett kerngesunde
menschen sind also ja meine eltern sind
natürlich auch gesund die haben jetzt
auch keine krass und vorerkrankungen
aber für solche leute wird es halt
schwierig gerade so leute die halt herz
vorerkrankungen haben oder krebs oder so
oder allgemeinen geschwächte immunsystem
oder leute die älter sind die das ist
halt nicht so spaßig mit dem klavier ist
das muss man ganz klar sagen allerdings
möchte ich euch nur weil die leute die
meine videos schauen sind zu 90 prozent
zwischen 18 und 24 jahre sagt zumindest
die statistik ich glaube ich noch ein
bisschen jünger aber vor sollte das
eigentlich kein problem sein
das ist also ich finde man sollte sich
jetzt nicht verrückt machen man sollte
jetzt keine panik schieben davon hat
keiner was ich selbst war beim arzt habe
dich den crawler virus falls ihr euch
das jetzt gerade fragt weil ich ja auch
ein bisschen husten bin und meine stimme
ein bisschen kaputt und alles mögliche
also mir geht's eigentlich gut obwohl
ich nicht so wirke obwohl ich viele habe
bisher am husten bin blabla
aber ich kenne die typischen peter
grippe nee das ist das was mich nur ein
bisschen bei mir wurde das ich bin seit
sechs tagen liege ich im bett und bin
krank obwohl ich mich wirklich immer
außer natürlich ab und zu gehe ich auch
feiern trinken bisschen alkohol
selbstverständlich aber ich ernähre mich
wirklich eigentlich immer gesund klar
wurde pizza als logisch aber immer also
unter der woche montags bis freitags bin
ich eigentlich wirklich string morgens
eine heiße zitrone
ich mache mich draußen war ich war schon
die hände danach wenn ich nach hause
komme ist halt auch ganz wichtig sich
rohner virus muss man auch noch mal
sagen wenn wir jetzt mit leuten
unterwegs seid die im krisengebiet waren
erst mal solltet ihr es gar nicht sein
als jetzt trotzdem sei dann
bleibt er auf abstand auch wenn es
vielleicht ein bisschen kommen wir mal
ein bisschen action ihr auch wenn es
vielleicht dann unhöflich wirkt im
ersten moment vermeidet auch handschläge
vielleicht zu irgendwelchen leuten wo
jetzt ist okay die zeigen
krankheitssymptome zeigen kroder also
bewährt ueli habe husten will ich jetzt
nicht hingehen und sagen ey bruder check
geben küsschen links küsschen rechts auf
die wange dies das würde ich jetzt ein
bisschen vermeiden er bzw
ein bisschen zurückschrauben allerdings
bin ich immer noch nicht der meinung
dass man in panik verfallen sollte oder
feist bot jetzt alle konserven mit
leerzukaufen
finde ich sehr bedenkenswert sage ich
mal
aber ja oft komplette thema das video
zeige ich zurück zu kommen und auf den
titel zurück zu kommen
ich bin krank und das hier ist das
schlechteste video das sich hier
hochgeladen habe es tut mir unfassbar
leid falls ihr euch das video ist hier
angeschaut hat weil das heißt einfach
dass ihr glaube ich gerade absolut gar
nichts zu tun
wenn es nach mir gehen würde wäre ich
ist jedoch ob man bin ich so schlechte
dieser kacke dann fließt hier nach unten
jetzt haben wir gehen würde dann oder
eine ahnung wenn ihr nicht gemessen
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen wollte aber
es gibt viele andere youtuber die sind
gerade nicht krank machen super content
gerade da könnt ihr gerne vorbeischauen
ich weiß nicht ob ich morgen was
hochladen werde ich weiß nicht wie sich
das mit den fieber entwickeln wird ich
weiß nicht ob ich jemals wieder gesund
werde
d also ich mache ich keine sorge ich
glaube übermorgen soll ich auf jeden
fall wieder fit sein so dass es
vernünftig tägliche ablauf kommen werden
mit meinem vernünftigen normalen schnitt
und ich mache mir eigentlich keine
großen sorgen dass ich jetzt irgendwie
in mir ein paar tagen den grabsteinen
online bestellen muss auch wenn ich mal
instagram stories ab und zu so wirke
warte kriegt in das jetzt ganz
ungünstigen situation
ich dachte ich krieg den das
unterschätzt man immer so ein bisschen
naja gut freunde jetzt hat auch die
musik aufgehört und jetzt habe ich
trotzdem die austro musik reingepackt
also ein bisschen schritt ist hier
dennoch drin
es tut mir einfach leid mein komplettes
erscheinungsbild ich hab mir vor ich gar
kein video hochladen mache ich einfach
so ein kurzes update video zeigt euch
wie es mir geht sage euch war ja gerade
meiner einschätzung so zum bruder virus
hat ja auch einige von euch interessiert
habt ihr mir bei instagram geschrieben
wenn euch das video hier vielleicht
heute dennoch gefallen hat sagt mir das
gern mit einem daumen hoch ich kann noch
nicht genau sagen was morgen ab morgen
ein video kommt oder ob kein video kommt
gleich am morgen bei den live stream
aber ich weiß nicht ob das auch so eine
gute idee ist mir geht es einfach gerade
nicht so gut und ich habe mir gedacht
bevor gar nix kommt
update ich euch einfach so ein bisschen
das tut mir leid dass ich einmal
geschnitten habe aber ich glaube ich
glaube ihr habt verständnis dafür
ich habe euch lieb bleibt gesund und
schaut